I remembered me in 1999 I'm 21 years old
I just got out of the army and I'm so
broke I mean I literally don't have a
penny to myself to go to the gas station
to fill up one gallon in my car I have
nothing going on I'm looking for a job
I'm back in LA and certain events took
place my dad had a heart attack big
heart attack that he had he almost has
to when he didn't and had a very big
emotional moment and one of the things
that started happening was everything in
my mind became so urgent so urgent about
getting rid of all the financial
difficulties I was having on my life at
that time forty nine thousand dollars in
that credit card that all this other
stuff that out going on and it was so
strange because I had a group of friends
that I was hanging out with and every
time we would get together whether it
was Labor Day Memorial Day Veterans Day
em okay no matter what it was there was
always a reason to have a barbecue and
there were always excuses to not work
and it was so crazy to me because this
is what I made a decision to that that
time I said why is it that we're doing a
barbecue to [ __ ] about your boss to
[ __ ] about your job to [ __ ] about how
difficult life is to [ __ ] about how you
and your girlfriend are arguing over
finances to [ __ ] about how much your
mom and that are bitching about money
and finances and all this other stuff
and you want me to do a barbecue here
all this crap
why not freaking go sell something on
Memorial Day let's go sell something on
Labor Day let's go sell something on MLK
Day let's go sell something like started
in business why are we bitching so much
my finances you lose the right to [ __ ]
about finances if you want to freaking
happen out barbecue all the damn time
and I wonder sometimes when people call
me Tilly pepper you don't understand you
know I read this article that it's not
healthy for you to not get a full nine
hours of sleep because Huffington Post
that there's a scroll that crap people
don't work in art or very long time you
know what's not healthy here's what's
not healthy
two out of three marriages end up at a
divorce number one reason is finances
that is not healthy it's not healthy
it's not healthy when a 17 18 year old
kid that is purely intelligent wants to
go become a doctor didn't end up getting
a scholarship somebody didn't get the
scholarship for whatever reason is that
yet but this gets it end up being a
doctor mom and I don't have the finances
to send him to school and it's not to
say the government should pay for it is
to say mommy daddy instead of watching
that damn show every night where you
would come home at five o'clock why
don't you go sell something mom why
don't you go sell something that why
don't you get to work why do you watch
every single Laker game turn off the
damn TV and watch that Yankees game or
whatever you're watching turn it up go
so something pops
Mongo's so something troubling indeed
this is a very very important message to
give you today because I just see I am
so sick and tired of people bitching
about finances who only want to work
9:00 to 5:00 if you only want to work
9:00 to 5:00 stop complaining about your
financial situation and do something
about it if it's a Labor Day go labor if
it's Memorial Day go sell it's not a
reason to do barbecue is to recognize
the people that died on that that serve
for the country and I MLK's for one man
who had the courage to put his life on
the line for a race for a color he did
that do you think he was worried about a
barbecue no and we celebrate MLK Day
it's not a day to do barbecue it's a day
for us to go out and become free for you
to go out there become free you mean
watching this you're not an American
nuclear what Memorial Day Labor Doom MLK
Day is but it matters that you go become
free so if you're having a barbecue and
you're complaining about finances zip it
instead of the barbecue pull a few
friends aside and say guys why don't we
start a business together why don't we
start selling something together finally
going big for families man you're sick
of finances I started talking about this
language your body starts that patio so
weird man it's Friday we got to go to
the club - Saturday bro so lame
everyone's at the beach and then it's
insane I don't I don't want to hear it
anymore I don't want to go hang out with
a bunch of broke people at the beach I
don't want to do it I want to own a
private beach I don't want a freaking
party with everybody off a struggle
financially
and you know what the reality is need to
do you you don't you think you were put
on this planet to go out and barbecue
with all these other guys that are
struggling financially never for flu
your profits you're doing something big
with your life I don't think so not you
so instead of looking for reasons to do
a barbecue and looking for excuses to
not work start looking for reasons to go
sell something to start a business and
figure out a way to get out of the
financial difficulties that you and your
families might be facing